foreign
Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies have
long been a topic of debate many argue
about the pros and cons of these digital
currencies the introduction of Bitcoin
as legal tender fuels these discussions
even more and makes them all the more
present
although it will take some time for its
full impact to be felt Bitcoin
represents a potential solution to
Global poverty or the prevailing gap
between the rich and poor
in September 2021 El Salvador became the
first country in the world to adopt
Bitcoin as legal tender
[Music]
thank you
the start of the new currency was
definitely bumpy the country had to deal
with various technological problems and
an additional slump in bitcoin's price
moreover people are still very
suspicious of transactions between
dollars and the tiny amounts of
cryptocurrencies major franchise chains
based in the capital have started
accepting Bitcoin via smartphone in
addition the Salvadorian government
introduced a network of 200 chivo ATMs
to familiarize consumers with Bitcoin if
president Nai bokile's plan to introduce
Bitcoin is a success it is very possible
that this change will benefit the
impoverished Salvadorian economy
[Music]
foreign
officials in El Salvador claim that the
introduction of Bitcoin will increase
the affordability of services expand
payment options and increase Financial
Innovation
success could also encourage other
countries to adopt cryptocurrencies
strengthening the possibility of
reducing poverty worldwide
Nick Carter of Castle Island Ventures
was one of the first to connect with El
Salvador's president via social media
encouraged him to introduce Bitcoin as a
means of payment
you hosted a historic Twitter spaces
last night you started talking about
Bitcoin because that's how you talk
about online and then I think Jack
showed up and a bunch of people and then
the president of El Salvador showed up
and you talked and you single-handedly
turned around the coin because now it
rallied today but in your understanding
and in your conversation uh with the
president what is the main benefit to
this new law how will it in theory um
help the economy and the people of the
country
well it was a fascinating time because
the president president bukele joined us
on Twitter live as this law was being
voted in and we could actually hear the
Clapping the votes from the
Parliamentary chamber uh to discuss with
bitcoiners on Twitter uh the merits of
the law uh the objective seems to be
making using Bitcoin as a actual medium
of payment medium of exchange much more
frictionless in the country eliminating
all capital gains taxes which is you
know of course a big impediment to
actually using this thing as a currency
uh you know potentially in service of
making uh you know Bitcoin based
remittances uh cheaper and less
frictional for instance so that seems to
be sort of the main thrust of the law
what can we extrapolate then uh as far
as what the future holds Beyond El
Salvador here do you think we'll see
other I guess legitimate countries like
El Salvador Embrace this and other
larger countries
well in following the Salvadorian news a
number of politicians in Latin America
many of them younger on the millennial
side signaled their affinity for Bitcoin
as well
um and made noises about potentially
introducing similar ideas uh we'll see
if any of that actually transpires we
know that Bitcoin cryptocurrency stable
coins have very high penetration in
places like Colombia and Argentina uh
you know Latin America is certainly no
stranger to Sovereign defaults or you
know periods of high inflation or
monetary repression so we see high
penetration there there's certainly a
class of policy makers that see an
opportunity to gain favor by signaling
their Affinity uh and uh you know we'll
see what happens but this is the first
El Salvador is the first non-paria state
to really legitimize and legalize
Bitcoin usage uh in in sort of its
intended way so you know it seems like a
big c change frankly a big sea change
that only though
meant that we saw a seven percent rally
you're still seeing Bitcoin in and of
itself under pressure significantly of
its highs that we saw previously in the
year Nick
are you expecting the issue for El
Salvador going forward is also the
ongoing volatility within Bitcoin as
well is there any point we're expecting
that to just reduce a little bit so we
see it more regularly used as a currency
not just by those that are suffering
significant inflation or indeed seeing
an issue with a hard currency Peg
it's hard to say bitcoin's volatility is
seen to be money as as uh you know a
natural consequence of the scarcity of
the system of course something like gold
which is you know similarly kind of a
commodity fixing issuance doesn't
evidence such significant volatility but
Bitcoin is still early in its life and
uh you know very patchally adopted
globally and also in terms of El
Salvador it's a very small country
um you know foreign exchange reserves in
the single digit billions
um the fund that president bukele was
talking about establishing which would
hold a position in Bitcoin uh he
signaled they would be in kind of the
150 million dollar range so smaller than
many kind of crypto hedge funds uh so
while this does represent Sovereign
adoption it's not sovereign adoption by
the largest sovereigns just yet so we'll
see but in as much as using Bitcoin as a
medium of payment or a bridge currency
you don't necessarily have to have
exposure to the asset for a long period
of time time in order to sort of take
advantage of its its nice properties
I think the Bitcoin Community has a
history of like sort of getting excited
about certain people and then they break
your heart uh Elon Musk is probably the
most prominent one and ever then he sort
of he stabbed you in the back are you
worried that uh the president won't have
a commitment to bitcoin per se and next
month it's like and now we've asked the
ethereum foundation to digitize health
records and xrp to modernize our banking
system and then it'll just be like a
bunch of crypto buzzwords in a few weeks
well what was notable about this bill
that was passed was it specifically says
Bitcoin and all of the messaging is
about the lightning Network and about
these Payment Systems built on top of
Bitcoin and there's relatively little
messaging around cryptocurrency more
generally so the commitment in this case
does seem to be regarding Bitcoin of
course who knows what's going to happen
in the future and in fact there is going
to be plenty of narratives out there
around Bitcoin is consorting with you
know someone that is perceived by many
in the west as an authoritarian uh
dictator but any adoption of Bitcoin at
The Sovereign level is interesting and
noteworthy we don't shy away from that
there has been adoption of Bitcoin by
other sovereigns that you know are
considered Pariah States and nobody
tries to hide that so it's certainly
interesting to watch this play out in
real time
[Music]
in South America there have already been
several hyperinflations in the past in
Venezuela for example too many new
banknotes are in circulation today
evaluating cash
unlike the wealthy people of the western
world people from developing countries
are mostly excluded from the benefits of
a higher money supply
their Surplus capital is far too small
to be invested efficiently the majority
simply do not have the ability to earn
enough interest to protect their Savings
in this regard orbs reported that only
about 70 percent of el Salvadorans are
even banked
[Music]
Bitcoin can help because its Supply is
finite and therefore limited according
to the Bitcoin Foundation there will
only ever be 21 million Bitcoins
therefore when the demand for Bitcoin
increases its value also increases the
limited nature of the currency prevents
inflation helping to reduce Global
poverty unlike most national currencies
central banks cannot control Bitcoin
either as it runs entirely on a
decentralized blockchain there are no
transaction fees which helps poorer
people in developing countries to
increase their return on investment
without additional fees cryptocurrencies
allow even the poorest people to make
investments over which they have full
control since cryptocurrencies pre-bit
outside interference in Investments they
create a Level Playing Field for
everyone
that the introduction of a digital
currency can indeed have positive
effects on the stability of a country is
shown by the example of Venezuela the
start of villu is helping the people of
Venezuela in their fight against
hyperinflation
I'm Simon Chamorro I'm the co-founder
and CEO of value and we're a product
that helps Venezuelans living in
hyperinflation protect their money from
losing value receive remittances and pay
locally to buy food and medicines
both businesses and consumers are able
to exchange goods and services with each
other paying in cryptocurrency
the vision for us is to increase
economic freedom
[Music]
Venezuela is known for its political and
economic instability
hyperinflation has caused the Bolivar to
lose 99.9 percent of its value in just
two years
wealthy Venezuelan families saw their
fortunes disappear and the poor were
pushed even further into desperation
Simon shamoto knows this story all too
well growing up in Venezuela essentially
wherever my dad and my mom were able to
build during their life was lost when
the economy started to fail we for
example had water shortages or like
electricity blackouts across the country
money was starting to get hyperinflated
this is not like a sad story that I'm
trying to tell this is the reality of
most Venezuelans more than 99 of the
Venezuelans lost everything they've
built because the country failed
all of the Venezuelans Savings of most
middle class people went to zero I knew
I wanted to build something I had to
find my purpose I always knew I wanted
to start a company and to build things
which is a reason why I started
industrial design with the hypothesis
that I was going to be able to build
things I didn't pursue that career but I
learned a lot of things that got me into
Tech so I found crypto through Tech I
felt passionate about the technology and
then when I understood the potential of
crypto I realized that Venezuela is
potentially the best place to do this at
a massive scale
the reality is if we deconstruct
cryptocurrencies the base most basic
thing is that it helps disintermediate
and this may have the possibility to
change society as we know it the main
problem Venezuelans are going through
right now is hyperinflation
hyperinflation is just a byproduct of
total mismanagement of the country
Venezuela's descent into an impoverished
dictatorship put the devastating effects
of hyperinflation on full display for
the world to see lines for basic needs
extreme shortages of food and medical
supplies civil Strife violence and and
the citizens spared were the ones who
could move their currency out of
Venezuela to other more stable
currencies like the US dollar a luxury
mostly saved for the ultra Elite but
Simon's platform value promises the
opportunity for everyday Venezuelans to
protect themselves from hyperinflation
by way of cryptocurrency and according
to him the unstable conditions of his
country are the perfect breeding ground
for such an experiment nobody trusts the
currency or the government people are
looking for Solutions in a place where
people are trying to survive the barrier
of trying new things is much lower so
diesel dollars table coins
cryptocurrencies people are going to be
willing to try it with a little bit of
money and then slowly kind of get there
our main objective right now as a
company is to enable Merchants to accept
digital dollars as a minimum of payment
and so people have to use the the
boulevard less and less
we're focused on building a product that
serves from the richest person with a
lot of education and Technical literacy
from the lowest in comparison with very
low education and low technical literacy
in a country like Venezuela where the
minimum wage is one dollar
you have a situation where most people
are starting their own little business
selling hot dogs or selling the local
food called arepas or whatever they do
but they sell it to their community and
you have these hyper local communities
so we want to help them accept payments
in dollars in indeed to Dollars to
stable coins and then onboard users the
more consumers that pay in dollars the
better for the merchants the more
Merchants that accept it the better for
the consumer
[Music]
so far we've moved millions of dollars
we've helped more about than 150 000
households 30 000 monthly active users
and is working
the reality is is that economic freedom
it's only directly tackled by The
Innovation that is cryptocurrencies
but we can't forget that Venezuela has
tried this already el Petro was a
proposed cryptocurrency backed by the
country's most abundant resource oil
while El Petro was widely considered a
resounding failure many experts agree
that the experiment was a necessary step
in establishing cryptocurrency for the
future and Simon is convinced that its
foundations namely blockchain technology
remain stronger than ever and ready for
another more practical iteration
blushing is really a paradigm shift for
the human race it's one of the most
important things that has happened in
recent history what you're starting to
see is companies starting to completely
build their products on top of this
blockchain it's almost like it's
creating its own economy
if there's a way to provide more
stability and economic freedom and
Financial Freedom to Venezuelans without
crypto I would rather for that to happen
than for me to be successful with a
product that doesn't bring value to to
the people
operates Outside The Current financial
system that is there is no Central
Authority since it is not yet possible
for governments and Banks to interfere
with Bitcoin transactions this means
that people cannot be discriminated
against when using the currency
cryptocurrencies are also very secure
and difficult to steal which further
limits potential corruption one problem
with external Aid however is making sure
that the money ends up in the hands of
those who desperately needs it for
example much of the 130 billion that the
United States has paid to Afghanistan
since 2001 has been diverted by Afghan
leaders corrupt governments that claim
such a for themselves are particularly
common problems with several African
countries the use of Bitcoin and its
ability to prevent corruption can help
reduce this problem
do you doubt that the U.S will make a
similar move what's your take
well I think what we really see now is
quite a few projects underway both in
the U.S and abroad where central banks
are beginning to explore the development
of their own digital currencies so we've
seen that in places like China we've
seen the development of the digital
dollar project beginning to get some
traction here in the U.S But ultimately
this is not necessarily something that
should be construed or understood to be
a competitor with decentralized
protocols like Bitcoin but rather I do
see in the future that we will see these
Sovereign currencies Fiat currencies do
uh you know make the move on to a you
know blockchain based system
so how is this uncertainty impacting
where you're placing your bets I mean do
you have any plans to pitch a tent on
bitcoin beach in El Salvador anytime
soon
you know I think this has been a really
interesting time in the market you know
seeing moves like what we're seeing in
El Salvador seeing an environment where
we have some of the world's most
followed most famous investors publicly
coming out in support of Bitcoin seeing
you know major corporations begin to add
Bitcoin to their balance sheets you know
this is an environment unlike we've ever
seen before around this asset class and
I certainly think the last 18 plus
months for many people in the investment
Community have really solidified the
staying power that digital currencies
now have and investors are now you know
waking up to the potential
um that they can provide to their
portfolios
now I just spoke with coinbase
co-founder Fred ursum of the crypto
Venture Capital firm Paradigm who's
legitimately concerned that China will
surpass the U.S in crypto and especially
when it comes to regulation what do you
think
well I think what we're seeing here in
the U.S is a regulatory regime that has
been very in tune with cryptocurrency
and you know certainly firms like
grayscale are a really strong example of
a firm that's working within the asset
class but also within the existing
regulatory framework and what you're
seeing is now guidance that has really
given investors the confidence they need
to approach and be involved in the asset
class whether it's SEC cftc IRS treasury
fincen you name it and what we have seen
in other parts of the world like China
is a you know a stance that I think is a
little bit more prohibitive at times
around decentralized currencies like
Bitcoin so the you know to Fred's point
and I and I do sometimes agree with that
that stance that there is a little bit
of you know perhaps an arms race around
this as to which countries and which
regulatory regimes are going to be most
accommodated to The Innovation that's
taking place around these types of
assets and ensuring that the companies
and the people that are using them you
know kind of get that first mover
Advantage so there is some some element
of time being of the essence around some
of those initiatives
well and speaking of that we're
expecting an SEC decision in the near
future on bitcoin ETFs that decision was
expected this week it was pushed where
do you expect that decision to land
well you know we've been engaged with
the SEC on bitcoin ETFs dating all the
way back to 2016. uh we are a hundred
percent committed to converting our
Flagship fund uh great scale Bitcoin
trust into an ETF when the regulatory
environment is ready to make those kinds
of approvals and from our engagement
with regulators and our seat within the
financial services and crypto
communities we're really encouraged by a
lot of the progress that's being made
but I think the SEC has been very very
clear that there are certain aspects of
the crypto ecosystem that they're
looking to achieve a certain level of
maturation and so they're trying to
ensure that these markets and inherently
before they approve products around them
are void of manipulation have
surveillance sharing agreements in place
in the spot market and ultimately may
have some of the same types of investor
Protections in place that they may have
around equities and other asset classes
that they also oversee so while we're
certainly making Progressive you know I
think clearly we're not quite there just
yet
now obviously there's been a ton of
volatility are we back on the upswing or
are we going to see some more lows
before we get back to uh a high upcycle
well I think based on investor demand
we've seen this time and again we've
seen either leverage coming out of the
ecosystem that's caused a correction in
the price of Bitcoin or other news or
other events affecting the price of
Bitcoin but typically the investor
Behavior has been one of using these
pullbacks and price opportunistically to
add to their positions right if they if
they fundamentally still believe in the
same investment thesis but that
investment is now available to them at
10 or maybe 15 cheaper than it was a
week or two or a month ago then
investors often use these types of
periods of time to really add to those
positions and ultimately build uh you
know a diversified portfolio you know
when you see those pullbacks
what do you think of Elon musk's latest
comments I mean does the does the
Whiplash bother you saying one thing
then saying another
well you're talking to someone that's
been around crypto for about eight years
now and so I've seen no shortage of
movements in in the crypto price but I
do think some of the commentary that
Elon Musk has made has really been
focused on ESG and some of the carbon
footprint and energy consumption
concerns around Bitcoin mining and I
think when it comes to that it's really
important that we stick to the facts you
know I think the latest statistic is
about 75
of minors are using renewable energy as
part of their energy mix so that could
be Hydro that could be
um you know wind it could be solar and
it's important to zoom out a little bit
Emily and realize we're only 10 or 12
years into the life cycle of crypto
assets and so it definitely stands to
reason that this is an opportunity for
this industry to continue to innovate um
continue to reduce its carbon footprint
um and ultimately kind of rise to the
challenge that's being presented to it
how should we think about this then the
biggest test for Bitcoin being adopted
as legal tender well you know this is an
exciting moment for the for the
cryptocurrency community because of
course this is what they said will
happen right I mean you know El Salvador
it's it's it's it's not you know at the
center of global Finance but still this
is this is the first test for Bitcoin
and they will be very excited about this
and you know this is um this isn't
something that has ever been done before
so just for that reason I think this is
very exciting
how much of a worry are we that this is
going to be a buy the rumor sell the
fact event El Salvador only has 400
Bitcoins it's not very much uh so you
know 20 20 million dollars worth
um what's the expectation from here
yeah I think that's that that is a risk
and there was this uh push from the uh
Reddit and Twitter Community to say look
let's go out and buy Bitcoin on you know
on the 7th of September on today so that
they can get out there and push the
price higher but I mean we've already
seen the price rally 40 since that
announcement was made so I think there
is a risk here that you know the the the
air gets let out of the rally somewhat I
do think however that there's a lot of
exciting things happening right now in
the crypto space and one of them is also
a US ETF potentially coming so there's
just there's there's just signs that it
is being adopted more widely and I think
that will be exciting for them now the
painting picture for us idea so what it
really means if a country adopts this as
their currency because I was looking at
photos of cash points right but you go
to the cash point to change your Bitcoin
into dollars so you still spend US
Dollars on the street is that how this
is well it's it's a two-tier system um
in in in El Salvador what they want they
want most people and big retailers to
accept Bitcoin so you would be able to
go there and use your cryptocurrency
wallet and pay directly but then also
um for smaller retailers that are not
able to do so
um they they will be they will be exempt
but for the most part I think most
retailers will have to accept it it's
worth noting that it is not very popular
a very popular law um in in El Salvador
surveys have shown that a lot of people
want to see this uh repealed but there
are good reasons for this um
particularly around remittances
thank you very much Eddie really good to
get your perspective on on these stories
Eddie Vanderbilt joining us there from
the markets live team
[Music]
Bitcoin and the world of
cryptocurrencies continue to be a much
discussed topic as more and more people
around the world become interested in
their potential for people in countries
that lack Financial stability
cryptocurrencies could be a viable
solution with this ability to stop
corruption prevent discrimination and
avoid inflation Bitcoin has the
potential to have a major impact on
global poverty
foreign
Pierce chairman of the Bitcoin
Foundation spoke in an interview about
bitcoin's continued growth and current
problems this is because especially for
people in rural areas it is mostly
impossible to make digital transactions
even today
Brock you were mentioning that you've
worked with so many other countries as
well you've spent time in El Salvador
can you talk to us a little about what
you're hearing in terms of other
countries that are thinking of adopting
this by way of El Salvador as well
well seeing how big a mass a massive
success this El Salvador launch has been
in terms of the impact it's having on
financial inclusion I'd say a lot of
governments are curious obviously I'm
not here to make decisions uh or advise
them per se on what to do I'm there to
give them the information so that they
can make decisions in terms of what they
think is best for their country but I'll
tell you there's a lot of interest there
is a lot of curiosity I've got I think
35 presidents in a queue right now I
literally can't move around the world
fast enough uh to give them all of the
information that they need and I'm
meeting with the ministers the heads of
the central banks I'm meeting with the
Business Leaders The the banks the
private sector there is a great deal of
interest because of the things we talked
about and now that there is a success
and data doesn't lie I think that this
is going to be a trend I think that
you're going to see a lot more adoption
and acceptance from governments around
the world especially in the Emerging
Markets Brock I'm really curious about
what what you think of this idea of so
many people not even hacking access to
5G Internet and mobile services I mean
there's still a barrier here to get
access to bitcoin as a currency if you
don't have the infrastructure to do that
and that's a problem here as well as in
Emerging Markets how do you think about
that issue when we're transforming this
economy to a digital economy
so you need connectivity it doesn't need
to be you know 5G but yes there is a
problem of connectivity around the world
it's not in cities it's typically in
rural areas because it's expensive using
land-based connections uh to reach
people where there's small populations
from a business perspective it's not
profitable now the good news is with
things like uh starlink and satellite
systems using air and space we are
finding mechanisms or methods of
delivering connectivity to rural areas
and we are not that far away from
everyone having access
um so it's coming it's a separate Lane
in terms of major problems in the world
that need to be solved but the good news
is it is being solved
but the launch of the world's largest
cryptocurrency got off a bumpy start in
El Salvador Bitcoin plunged about 17
within an hour falling to nearly forty
three thousand dollars before recovering
about half its losses the Bloomberg
Galaxy crypto index which lists some of
the largest digital coins lost as much
as 19 at times the reason for this
according to Stefan oulette managing
director and co-founder of frnt
financial was mysterious sell-offs or
sell-offs for which a legitimate reason
is only found after a considerable
amount of time these are much more
common with cryptocurrencies than with
other asset classes the crypto Market
remains far more PEC and Global the most
if not all other asset classes
billionaire Mike novogratz Chief
Executive Officer of Galaxy digital
Holdings and a longtime crypto
Enthusiast set the market for digital
currency in coins in particular has been
surging and oversold over the past eight
weeks interest from Individual investors
has skyrocketed due to large
institutions now investing in
cryptocurrencies
Mike you are known to buy the dip so
what are you buying and how much of it
well listen I think there's been a big
sell-off today I think we always have to
remember that crypto is still a retail
dominated uh ecosystem right we've had
institutions that are moving in by the
day and that's creating a lot of
excitement but there's lots of retail
money a lot of it's leveraged uh there
was about four billion dollars of
liquidations that happened in a short
period of time this morning right that's
mostly leveraged offshore in places like
FTX and finance and the market got too
long it got long for good reasons right
I think in the last eight weeks there
has been a giant realization that crypto
is not just Bitcoin being bought as a
hedge against Bad monetary and fiscal
policy but maybe more importantly it's
web 3.0 it's the internet of value
transfer uh and when you see companies
like Visa buying nft and saying they
think digital Goods is a big part of
their future Walmart and Amazon the two
biggest retailers in the world putting
up Help Wanted signs crypto engineers
and for crypto experts uh there's a
realization that this is a technology
play and no investor wants to miss the
next internet this is the next internet
and so there was a lot of great price
movement right we went from 29 000 to 53
000 in Bitcoin and you know from
whatever eighteen hundred all the way to
4 000 in ethereum uh Solana a new level
one for most institutions yeah has the
First on of the scene and so I think we
just got too excited and this was the a
little error being you know popped out
of the uh the balloon all right Mike we
do want to get your thoughts on Solana
but before we move on to that I am just
curious as to what role if any
governments in will have in this because
the El Salvador approach was of course
much more just a straight transactional
and we've seen sort of uh some of the
concerns uh as to sort of uh gravitating
to a transactional uh model for Bitcoin
and other crypto assets here with other
governments uh decide to get into this
what role do you think they would play
in this environment you know there's
there's two different sides to this
right governments are going to be very
very protective of their National
currencies right their ability to to tax
and quit currencies uh is is is
panamount to them existing in my space
and so I think they'll be okay with
payments you're going to see the rise of
stable points right China's issue one
you'll see them in almost every major
country uh you know basically wrapped
versions of those National currencies
um and I think things like Bitcoin which
in the west really are being used to
store value people aren't using it as a
transaction currency I think what's
unique in El Salvador is you know 20 of
their GDP comes from reminiscence and so
you can see lots of those remittances
people sending Bitcoin back across
oceans uh from the U.S to El Salvador
and the locals either keep it in Bitcoin
because they're worried about the dollar
remember they have a dollarized economy
or converting it and spending it uh in
the local economy and so you know
they're kind of unique in that respect
and we'll see you know maybe it gets
used as a transactional currency I've
never thought it would be partly because
I think it's going to keep going higher
and why would you spend something that's
going to keep going higher well could
you argue though why would you spend on
something on days like today where 10
minutes later it drops 10 you know could
you make the case that like you were
hinting that Taylor if you're such a
good Trader you know what time to buy
the pizza
paying a Bitcoin in dollars I should
hire you well it's really difficult to
understand in the short term where
markets are going yeah
um in the longer term it's not so
difficult just look at a 15-year or 12
year long chart of the Bitcoin price and
think about the adoption that is
happening all over the world
um you know it is now an asset it's a
store of value I I like the kid when
Stan Rucker Miller said it was an asset
he's literally the best investor we've
seen in 30 years it's an ass and so
there are enough stand regulars or
enough institution that have said they
believe in this is the store of value
that it is a story about Mike all right
I just see it heading One Direction the
rollout today for El Salvador is choppy
there's a price drop there was
technology glitches at the beginning a
big go which you've agreed to buy is a
company that is working with El Salvador
what do you make of today's rollout and
what impact might it have on future
countries that may choose to go this
route Venezuela for example comes to
mind when a lot of people talk about
this
listen no matter whatever you're doing a
new technology roll out their religions
and so I guess the real question is come
back in six weeks are 12 weeks and let's
talk about how it's working you know for
the people of El Salvador for the system
itself
um you know I remember when Obama rolled
out Obamacare it was kind of a disaster
for a little while and they they sorted
the glitches out you know doing things
at scale is not easy and so I've got a
lot of faith that they'll get this right
you know the other thing is that we're
in a place where you see these young
Traders moving to the market across the
world and you see them buying nfts you
see them buying mean stops for the last
few few months what's the next big thing
that you think that the retail Trader
could catch on to
ah great question listen I think what
the lesson that we should learn from
this year is that
there are so many eyeballs out there
right and the faster you can see
something that catches those eyeballs
and builds Community the faster the
prices and so it literally is watching
for what the next idea is
um and then those communities become
much stronger than I ever thought they'd
be right I used to think okay Bitcoin
will work and and the the cryptos that
get a lot of use like ethereum things
building on it or in the salon a lot of
people are now building on it would work
but some of these other things wouldn't
they wouldn't have a purpose and I've
just been wrong right you look at
cardano or xrp they have these fan clubs
these very
uh
uh committed uh investors who are
bringing people into their community and
really expensive identity and so I think
what we're learning is the internet uh
and Retail interest
has created almost a new way to think of
investing it's can they build a
community can they make it sustainable
with you know bringing more people in
when money's cheap and there's so much
money floating around we're seeing you
know things I never thought would happen
I mean GameStop AMC perfect examples of
stocks that now don't that trade
completely divorced from the
fundamentals of the company
um and you're seeing that same thing in
crypto so when we talk about sort of the
way some investors gravitate to things
Mike I mean you mentioned Solana a
couple times here we talk about uh the
the token uh sort of tied to that and
just how fast it sort of sort of vaulted
itself into sort of public Consciousness
here I'm curious as to what you think is
driving that and about the
sustainability of some of these moves
here because that always seems to be the
question people have particularly people
new to this they sort of look at the
volatility and they wonder where where
is this sustainable well look you look
at you know Sam bankman free who runs
FTX who's 30 years old who just raised
900 million dollars for his company an
18 billion valuation from some of the
best investors in the world right he's a
legend in this space and he's the backer
of Solana uh and so that's his ecosystem
so people are betting on Sam uh as more
people come in they get excited right
institutions are coming in
um and it hit a it hit a critical point
of acceleration where now it's a thing
what's a blockchain a blockchain is a
database that we all share Solana is
exciting because it's easier to build on
because it's really fast
right the spouse of ethereum it's faster
because it's not nearly as decentralized
it's not nearly as secure and safe in
some ways right there's only you know uh
a couple dozen validators of the Solana
blockchain where there's thousands on
the ethereum blockchain right now
consumers don't seem to care right it's
decentralized enough and Regulators
don't seem to care there is a fair
question will in time Regulators say
we're not going to let this business
infrastructure
for our country of the world be built on
blockchains that aren't decentralized
like that's up for grabs you know that's
that's that's really in the means uh
right now that's not what the Market's
focused on the Market's focused on fast
is better and can they get people to
build on it and is there excitement
around it and so you know Luna Lunas and
other blockchain and I have big
investments in full disclosure the one
from Korea he's like the sandbankment
free he's pulling all kinds of products
and projects into his ecosystem Mike
unfortunately I have to be sort of the
boring one that brings us back to macro
I am wondering your call on rates are
you still short you betting rates to
climb from here I am short rates listen
you know they've had a decent little
move recently uh you know rates higher
prices lower I just think it's it's
impossible to own as much crypto as I do
or other assets equities and not want to
have a big rate short there is a
possibility that inflation is much
stickier than we think and accelerates
and that the FED will have to to move
sooner than they think the more
aggressive when they move
um they might not if they don't I think
assets keep going up for a long period
of time right as long as Cal keeps easy
money you can stay long your assets but
it feels like it's a it's a really
important Hedge for any portfolio that's
acid level
while the launch in El Salvador may have
been a possible cause of the
fluctuations in Bitcoin other variables
in the notoriously volatile crypto
sector may also be at play the central
Americans country's president nayi
bukele shared on Twitter that the
digital wallet used for the project can
now be downloaded after previously being
shut down due to technical issues
kivo is a Bitcoin wallet that allows
Salvadorian citizens and businesses to
send or receive payments in Bitcoin or
dollars anywhere in the world with kivo
and coins can be automatically converted
into US dollars also people in El
Salvador can use it to withdraw Bitcoin
Holdings for cash at Bitcoin ATMs
El Salvador has used the US dollar as
its National currency since 2001 when it
switched from the colon currency which
has issued in 1982. the main service
provider of the kivo wallet is
reportedly mexico-based exchange bitso
which is one of the largest
cryptocurrency exchanges in Latin
America bitso is working with the U.S
federal reserve member silvergate to
facilitate US dollar transactions for
the wallet
Emily Chang was in conversation with
Falcon excess Anya katorovich and
Bloomberg news's Michael McDonald to
discuss first impressions of the Bitcoin
rollout in El Salvador what does this
mean for Bitcoin what does this mean for
El Salvador
yeah well um you know as you mentioned
today it became legal tender in El
Salvador so uh what it means for Bitcoin
is um there are businesses in El
Salvador that will be required to accept
this if they're technologically able
we've seen several businesses today
start to accept it in El Salvador's a
lot of the larger ones McDonald's Pizza
Hut Starbucks we've seen transactions in
Bitcoin go through with some of these
larger chains in El Salvador also
citizens in El Salvador if they want
they can pay their taxes in Bitcoin as
well so um you know it did become legal
tendency it is going to operate
alongside the dollar for now in El
Salvador's so the dollar will still be a
national currency there as well so if
people don't want to use Bitcoin they
can use the dollar as well but
businesses will be required to to accept
it if they are technologically able as
of today
that said with the president saying to
buy the dip the technical glitch is Ayah
um should we be at all skeptical of
what's Happening Here
yeah that's a good question I think uh
you know it will take time I agree with
what Mike novograd said uh that this is
going to take a lot of time the
infrastructure in order to accept these
payments at scale uh will take a
significant Manpower uh and time and
investment as well and I think uh while
you know they're putting into place uh
thousands of ATMs uh the payment
processors in all of these different
businesses uh will take time but I think
for a country you know taking a step
back from what Michael said even around
some of those larger companies for a
country where a quarter of their GDP uh
is based on remittances I think this is
much larger in terms of the impact it
can have on the population and their
ability to uh you know move money across
borders uh that perhaps they can't today
uh but could if they just had a mobile
device
that said the population isn't
necessarily too excited about it Michael
I've seen polls that show a lot of
distrust uh among folks who live in the
country how widespread is that and could
that really slow down broader adoption
sure yeah we've seen polls in the weeks
leading up to this
um that about 70 percent of el
Salvadorans prefer to use the dollar to
bitcoin and we've also seen that about
70 percent have said that they would
like to see this Bitcoin law
um repealed so there is quite a bit of
skepticism of it on the ground I also
think there's a pretty large Financial
education learning curve um you know El
Salvador is is not a country that has a
lot of its citizens using the
traditional banking system uh it's so
it's you know cash is still King in El
Salvador
um so you know when you bring in this
sort of new technology like
cryptocurrency uh you know there is sort
of a hesitancy and there is uh sort of
some pushback at first
um so you know we are seeing
um a lot of people that are skeptical on
the ground there were a lot of questions
this morning with the chivo wallet
people couldn't download it it was
offline for a little while so the
government could fix some glitches so it
was a little bit of a rocky start and
there is there is some skepticism in El
Salvador
that said
Aya we've learned that we can never
judge Bitcoin on any game any given day
but what do you make of what's behind
this price move how much does this have
to do with El Salvador or is it
something else
yeah good question so it had nothing to
do uh really with El Salvador what we
saw today was very much what we saw
historically with uh bitmex liquidations
and so you were seeing uh over the last
couple of weeks a lot of whether it's
retail and institution on overseas
exchanges pile into derivatives products
for futures uh in products that maybe
they didn't necessarily know or were
funding correctly and there was a
leveraged waterfall and so cascading
liquidations happened uh this morning
now what I would really really
interesting uh is that this was very
much like a a bullish bear day and so we
saw that bounce back
um really quickly so as was discussed
earlier we dropped down to 44 we're now
at a support level of 47. I still see
think we're very much nearing that 60k
Mark and so we're continuing to see a
lot of I think of the 2.6 billion uh in
liquidations 1.1 billion was in Bitcoin
700 million was in ethereum and this was
largely driven by ethereum and defy
assets so still very bullish on
long-term view for price on bitcoin if
you you're that optimistic when do we
get to 60k and also we've had the
co-founder of of Kraken on the show who
say we're going to get to 100 before the
end of the year would you agree
yes I may not agree with with Jesse on
that uh he's he's very bullish but uh
you know that's a that's a good question
I think we'll see it in the next couple
of weeks really the what pushed us
Beyond 50k wasn't uh The Leverage on
bitcoin it was people uh you know
accumulating Bitcoin at spot and buying
it in size and what we're seeing at
Falcon X at least today is a lot of
these institutions took the opportunity
to buy the dip uh at not only Bitcoin
but across different assets and so I
think we'll we'll see that 60k uh sooner
than we expect I think in the next
couple of weeks the pro-bitcoin
government under President bukile
announced that his country will respond
to the recent price drop by buying 150
more coins and an average price of just
over 48 000 and 500 dollars
foreign it is safe to say that El
Salvador is one of the countries that is
very positive towards Bitcoin as it has
summarily legalized the primary
cryptocurrency since then the president
naive bikini and his government has
taken over every opportunity to further
capitalize on opportunities in the
market such as the plan to use BTC
profits to build schools and a
Veterinary Clinic just recently Achilles
announced plans to build a Bitcoin City
and invest an additional 500 million in
the value of security through a special
bond
off to a little bit of a rocky start is
the price on bitcoin itself crash in the
con and the country of course had a
little bit of trouble rolling out that
payment system joining us right now to
talk a little bit more about this is
Bitcoin Enthusiast Joe weisenthal who of
course has been following uh this
rollout for us oh Joe obviously you do a
lot more than that but you certainly
know a lot uh not only about Bitcoin
about about this whole ecosystem here
yeah I'm just curious as to what you
generally expected from the start of a
country even though it's a small country
using this as legal tender you know it's
hard for me to imagine that the
existence of another currency will
itself amount to this big transformation
but it would not surprise me if at the
margins or maybe to his substantial
degree it does bring in foreign direct
investment obviously a lot of actual
Bitcoin enthusiasts investors
technologists in the space are very
excited about what's going on there and
so the idea that perhaps they could set
up shop uh in the country is uh minors
developers and so forth uh perhaps also
uh Bitcoin tourism it would not be uh
surprising if one effect is to
essentially bring in uh more outside
capital
we know you know obviously one of the
most important things here will be for
other countries thinking about this Joe
uh some of the learning that happens
here what are you watching most closely
what do you think will be most
interesting about how this works and who
uses it and what the challenges are well
I think it'll be really interesting to
see uh you know a few things one is do
people use it as a spending currency or
you know most people in the US and
develop markets who uh own Bitcoin
mostly own it as an investment so
that'll be interesting
um there's also interesting
technological questions the degree to
which uh people find it easy to use uh
the various solutions that are being
developed whether it's the government's
wallet or another wallet that'll be
really interesting to watch because that
might inform whether other countries uh
try to adopt something similar so I
guess just usage patterns in general
what apps and how whether it's spending
uh investment those are all the
interesting things to track
I want to bring in Nick Carter uh
partner at Castle Island Adventures Nick
hosted a chat on social with the
president of El Salvador encouraging him
to adopt Bitcoin not long before the
country did exactly that um so Nick uh
we won't say that it was your brainchild
but certainly you were part of the
conversation with the leadership there
what are you watching most closely here
now that they have taken this step
well I'm curious to see the extent to
which uh second layer networks like the
lightning Network actually get
utilization apparently it looks like the
official chivo app will support this
overlay Network
um and so I'm very curious uh as as Joe
says as well to see whether salvadorians
actually embrace uh Bitcoin as a medium
exchange so far the evidence is that
Salvadorans are mostly bemused about the
moon uh but you know it'll be very
interesting to see if they actually use
it at Merchants well that's what I'm
curious about Nick I mean obviously
there's the Bitcoin faithful and then
you have some institutions that see the
investment opportunity uh within it but
of course trying to convince just
average people on the ground to use this
in a transactional way has to be a bit
of a hard sell and we've seen some data
showing uh polling out of El Salvador
saying something like 70 of the public
doesn't really want this thing how do
you overcome that how does this country
sort of Mount that type of public
perception and opposition to something
that they seem to be tethering their
future to
well I'd be surprised if Bitcoin became
the dominant medium of Exchange in the
country I expect dollars to be the
predominant solution for the foreseeable
future it is a little bit uh surprising
that the boo Kelly Administration has
pushed Bitcoin as a medium of exchange
so firmly when at The Sovereign level it
seems like the most obvious thing to do
would be to adopt it you know in their
foreign exchange reserves uh as kind of
a gold-like analog
whereas at the brick and mortar Merchant
level Bitcoin is not a popular tool nor
has it really ever been uh so it's a
little bit surprising to me to see their
emphasis uh in sort of you know that
transactional mode Nick what do you see
is the upside scenario here for so
obviously look a lot of bitcoiners such
as yourself have been very enthusiastic
very excited about this news what does
success look like either for Bitcoin or
more importantly what do you think if uh
you know success could mean for El
Salvador
well for El Salvador they're going to
have to normalize their relations with
the international institutions like the
IMF there's a lot of uncertainty that
they're they need to be resolved uh
investors in Salvadoran debt are pretty
concerned uh and so I'd like to see uh
yields come down a little bit but
generally speaking I think a relatively
smooth rollout the chivo wallet appears
to be working it's in the App Store so
um sort of in theory it works
um it would be I think damaging to the
effort if the blue Kelly Administration
started to enforce article 7 in the law
really aggressively against Merchants
that didn't offer Bitcoin
um you know transaction settlement so as
currently conceived this law is actually
more of a force tender than a legal
tender law and it actually mandates
Merchant acceptance if they start to
enforce that really aggressively I think
that would be a pretty significant op to
explode for the boo Kelly Administration
it might trickle down the Bitcoin as
well
you see there'll be a
ble in terms of sort
of so it's there what would you expect
to see larger countries uh more kind of
globally integrated countries adopting
Bitcoin in the same way anytime soon
perhaps not embracing it as this medium
exchange uh which as I've said is is you
know a curious approach uh but as a sort
of non-sovereign digital gold like asset
that you can hold and use to diversify
your exposure away from Sovereign
currencies like the dollar to me that
seems like the most obvious approach El
Salvador to be clear is probably not the
first sovereign state to hold Bitcoin at
you know on its balance sheet uh it's
certainly rumored and quite plausible
that states like Iran Venezuela or North
Korea all hold Bitcoin in some capacity
they're the first ones to do it
explicitly though
um but yeah as as Bitcoin becomes more
of this gold-like asset and you know
fully undertakes that process of
maturity and financialization uh that's
where I'd expect to see uptake
um you know as as central banks
potentially look for this sort of
non-sovereign you know asset that they
can hold but just to be clear Nick so
when you talk about uptake you're
talking about uh these central banks
sort of building that up in its reserve
of the treasury in its reserves to a
level that I guess would maybe by
default just sort of force uptake
uh yeah that's what I would expect to
see in terms of sovereign adoption of
Bitcoin
um none of us really expected that the
First Nation to fully Embrace Bitcoin
would do it in terms of encouraging it
to become a dominant media Exchange
uh so you think do you think there's
going to be another country I mean
actually more importantly like Bitcoin
hasn't gone anywhere in a long time
price wise it went down quite a bit
since the highs earlier in the spring
then it's bounced back like what is the
next big Catalyst you're watching for
was it more on the national side is it
something on an ETF like what do you
think is going to be the next thing that
gets people excited about Bitcoin
because even with the recent crypto
rally it seems like people are really
more excited about like Solana or like
buying a JPEG of an ape
well you have to consider in context and
I think it's this macroeconomic drivers
that are really going to determine the
next few years of bitcoin's future
effectively uh if we get this kind of
sustained uh monetary repression with uh
negative real interest rates I think
assets like Bitcoin continue to look
attractive to investors Bitcoin itself
doesn't really have to change much
um it's sort of quite well understood
and of course there's things like an ETF
which would be uh you know further
financialization make it suitable for
other Market participants to get
exposure to but that's pretty
incremental at this point I think it
really just depends what's happening out
there and sort of the broader
macroeconomic environment
we know that they're as uh you know
plenty of uh of review happening at the
SEC and elsewhere from a regulatory
point of view about cryptos in general
uh and their use and their applications
uh what do you think where do you think
we are uh and how does this if in any
way change the Thinking by the SEC for
instance in the legitimacy of these
products and how they will be used by
perhaps even the Federal Reserve
well uh SEC chairman gunzler understands
Bitcoin very well
um and I think his opinion of it is sort
of fully uh complete uh and he's you
know I think carved it out uh as you
know something that's truly
decentralized uh he's made statements to
that effect uh now the remainder of the
crypto space especially to centralized
Finance on some of these you know crypto
Banks lenders seem to be in his
crosshairs I think the SEC is a more
activist SEC it's uh it just
fundamentally more active than the prior
SEC
um and has a number of sort of
litigations undergoing including with
ripple
um and gunsler has made some you know
pretty direct and aggressive statements
about the decentralized finance space
and I think the whole industry is kind
of expecting some sort of reprisal there
although we don't we don't know exactly
what form it's going to take yet what a
reprisal towards decentralized Finance
be bad for Bitcoin because it would say
oh all of crypto is on in the crosshairs
or would it be good in the sense that
non-bitcoin crypto is largely viewed as
a regulatory Arbitrage play that then
gets Stamped Out
it's a great question because Bitcoin is
not the dominant collateral type in
decentralized finance although it is
somewhat involved um any reprisals might
concern platforms or exchanges where of
course Bitcoin trades as well and it so
it might affect the liquidity profile
but it's a good point Bitcoin is
somewhat distinct from the broader
decentralized Finance movement
um that said I think uh you know
investor pessimism would percolate
throughout the whole industry on
probably adversely affect Bitcoin at the
same time
[Music]
currently we are experiencing a severe
correction on the crypto Market Bitcoin
is also clearly feeling this
a bitcoin's Crim plunge is dwarfed by
the sharp trading losses the collapse of
El Salvador's bonds which has driven up
El Salvador's financing cost the
country's foreign bonds posted the
world's worst performance in 2021 as
investors were spooked by peculus
unorthodox economic management and the
Bitcoin experiment
[Music]
extended fund financing with the help of
the international monetary fund has not
materialized due to multilateral lenders
concerns about Bitcoin
Akili has become a celebrity in a
Bitcoin Community for buying on price
drops and promising to build a tax-free
Bitcoin City on the country's Coast what
do analysts think of this buying the dip
strategy by the president
hey Charlie I want to start with you
because you wrote about retail Traders
buying the dip is there patients with
Bitcoin volatility is it wearing a
little bit thin
well with some of them so anytime you
see Bitcoin or other you know Mimi
assets start to decline you see this
barrage of tweets a Facebook posts of
Reddit posts saying quote unquote buy
the dip and a lot of retail investors by
this point in the year have bought some
of these dips but they've only seen
diffs continue and they've lost money so
with a number of the people that I spoke
with including a woman who lost about
two thousand dollars buying a dip that
kept dipping
um yes there is a you know a loss of
patience here
and so valdana let's talk about exactly
what happened yesterday because I was
off but it seemed like it was really bad
and I noticed in your story you had a
detail in there that some 3.7 billion
dollars of crypto liquidations occurred
in 24 hours what does that mean where
people basically being forced out of
their positions yeah so the decline
yesterday was really precipitous it was
so incredibly quick I think a lot of
people had been watching the charts and
and maybe guessing that Bitcoin was
going to hit 50 000 yesterday and cross
above it and then in a matter of minutes
you saw it just decline it wiped out 10
then 15 then 17 so certainly you had
some people who maybe aren't hodlers
meaning they're not holding on for dear
life and maybe potentially they got
scared and some of them sold out of
their positions but at the same time you
had had these really interesting
statistics about these liquidations
basically what happens is somebody can
borrow money and make bets on
cryptocurrencies and when those bets go
wrong your positions can actually get
liquidated so I was looking at data from
this company called buy bit they track
some of these Trends and so they saw
that some 330
000 of these Traders were liquidated
yesterday and that amounted to more than
three and a half billion dollars worth
of cryptocurrencies in yesterday's
sell-off so huge numbers really
precipitous Decline and you have sort of
a lot of these things at play but
certainly these liquidations were a big
part of yesterday's decline well what's
so interesting Bill Donna and Charlie is
it came on the day that El Salvador
adopted Bitcoin as legal tender so
Charlie I know you were watching this
closely because this was a very big test
for the idea of this being a well
cryptocurrency or at least legal tender
in a country what did you learn about
the the rollout the implementation of it
and and what that had to do with
yesterday's decline was there any
relationship with the sell-off that we
saw there and what happened in El
Salvador
yeah so the tweets really tell the story
here so this was billed as one of the
biggest tests for Bitcoin that you know
a country albeit small was going to
start accepting Bitcoin as legal tender
the president was touting this there was
you know quite widespread opposition but
this was seen as a test
um for Bitcoin as a currency that could
be accepted in you know uh retailers and
so before this happened a number of
Bitcoin supporters across social media
talked about how they wanted to try to
boost this in a sort of meme way people
were buying thirty dollars worth of
bitcoin which is the amount of money
that people in El Salvador were going to
be given um and this was you know hoping
to to support uh this rollout there were
technical issues that we saw very
quickly and a lot of disappointment and
so you know potential causation or at
least correlation there
um connected to the drop yesterday and
what people were seeing in El Salvador
El Salvador is thus the first country in
the world to adopt Bitcoin as a legal
currency the country has been using the
US dollar for more than 20 years and
continues its Bitcoin friendly course in
2022 the government has once again
injected several million dollars into
the controversial cryptocurrency
likewise El Salvador is planning to
build Bitcoin City the world's first
Bitcoin City
Bitcoin city is to be built in the
Eastern area of La Union president Nai
bukili recently announced it will be
powered by a nearby volcano okili said
the Plant City will be financed with
bonds that are also tied to Virtual
currencies the announcement was made
during an event at the country's big
long Latin American Bitcoin and
blockchain Conference
Samson Mao who attended the event along
with Buckley said in addition El
Salvador plans to issue one billion
dollar worth of bitcoin Bonds in 2022 ma
is an executive at blockstream a
blockchain technology provider
once funding is in place construction of
Bitcoin City could begin within 60 days
Akili said ma added that this city could
make El Salvador the financial center of
the world the government said it will
provide land infrastructure and load
taxes to attract investors quickly said
there will be no poverty income or
Municipal Taxes only value-added tax
government also already operate a
Bitcoin mining test project it is
located near another geothermal area
next to the tikapa volcano in the
eastern part of the country
the government plans to use about half
of the tax revenue to fund Bitcoin City
the other half will be used for local
Services wikili estimated that the
public infrastructure projects will cost
about 300 000 Bitcoins
the government currency supports Bitcoin
with a 150 million fund to encourage
Salvadorans to use Bitcoin the
government offer a 30 credit with the
use of digital wallets
Bitcoin was originally created to
operate outside of government control
Financial systems whether
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin can really
solve major problems of our current
Financial system remains to be seen
El Salvador has dared to take the step
into the future will other countries
follow suit
foreign